Eric is in Richmond Virginia welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show Eric hey Dave
thanks taking my call sure what's up hey
so I'm 30 years old
I currently make $75,000 a year pre-tax
after taxes probably like 47 ish three
years ago I made a dumb decision
and bought a $45,000 car I put five down
and took out a loan for just under
40,000 I currently owe 17,000 and my
monthly payment is 6:30 at a three point
nine percent interest rate mm-hmm
currently the car is worth twenty five
to twenty seven thousand dollars with a
trade-in or 30 to 32 if I private cell
which seems unlikely my question is
should I you know cut the poison before
it spreads where should I hang on to it
and you know we eat the payment and then
just drive it to the wheels fella good
rule of thumb and which would keep you
from ever doing this again is don't own
things with wheels and/or motors all
total in your life that equal more than
half your annual income because things
with wheels and/or motors go down in
value and you've got too much invested
in things that are going the wrong way
and so you violated that when you bought
the car today when you call me it
doesn't violate that it's worth twenty
five to thirty you make seventy five
okay and so if you like the car and you
can pay it off inside of two years and
be debt-free not counting your house
inside of two years and your baby step
two we call it I would keep the car what
kind of car is it and do you like it um
yet the Volkswagen Golf R I really love
it I could probably get it down in two
years but currently the maturity date is
three years but I could definitely push
for two if I had to I'm sorry I thought
you said you owed $17,000 correct yeah
how much other debt do you have zero
you're not you know in one year I have
been spinning habits which I'm working
on inside I guess okay well that's a
difficult it's kind of obvious with the
car you bought but the yeah I I I think
that's what you got to work on if you're
not going to put it get yourself in
order to pay it off within two years you
do need to
okay cool but you oughta pay it off in
one year oh and by the way 75,000 is not
take-home pay of 47,000 or something
screwed with your math possibly but I
think it's pretty close after insurances
401k all that stuff oh that's not a
Compaq take-home pay is after taxes
you're buying some of that stuff out of
your check okay and you're putting money
in a 401k yeah yeah stop that to get
this car paid off okay
so you're new to this whole thing that
we're talking about here right yes but
for the 401k like I get matched at 4%
do you think I should go down to 4% and
keep that or should I just kill it all
together until this cars paid off well
it depends on if you're gonna do what I
teach okay let's stop a second what we
teach folks to do is to walk a process
to become debt-free build your emergency
funds so that as you build wealth you're
not being counterproductive okay and so
I would teach you first to have $1,000
in the bank second to be debt-free the
third to have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses and only then
would you start your 401k regardless of
match because it's so important to lay a
foundation of debt-free and an emergency
fund under your financial house as you
start to build it and so as a temporary
measure yes I would stop the 401k 100%
but again that's only if you're gonna
get this frickin car paid off so you can
get back in the 401k okay so you got to
play the whole thing together or it
doesn't make sense
hold on I'm gonna send you a copy of the
book the Total Money Makeover you read
through that it outlines exactly why and
what I'm saying to do and then you'll
start to understand what I'm talking
about here because it's it's a more
encompassing answer than I can give you
in a minute and a half on the radio so
hold on I'll give you a copy of that